hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play run now this is me
getting more into the UM indie horror
games that I've been getting away from I
I know that I really like to support the
indie or game indie game community in
general so I'm gonna be playing a lot
more lately alright so this game is
based on the premise of running
basically you run and you keep running I
don't know much about it but it's
supposed to simulate the feeling of
being chased so I'm gonna assume that
any minute now a monster's gonna appear
behind me what did I do
what that oh what oh okay um I guess I
shouldn't turn around which is really
bad habit of mine I always turn around
in games so don't do that or else you'll
be claimed by it okay so anyway let's uh
hold down the shift to the entire time
what happens if I need to backtrack what
happens if I hit a dead end what happens
if I want to go in this building okay
yeah when you play this game play with
stereo headphones because it
Oh Oh is this whole building just a dead
end I don't even know what I'm looking
for if I'm looking for like a dog piss
and vinegar all right okay don't be an
idiot about this Oh God yeah all right
so when you play don't go in the
building and play with stereo headphones
because really does sounds like
something is right behind me so I gotta
find my way to the end before it kills
me I don't even know what the end is I'm
just gonna run into a bunch of dead ends
like no question asks oh lordy hi
seriously that's really good how they do
that it sounds like something is
breathing down my neck okay so I guess I
just got to go in these series of
buildings until I find some Oh Tess no
okay don't go into the building's
because buildings are not where you're
supposed to be that was dumb this guy
reduction now odds are it's pretty
simplistic in design but as you can tell
and as I play before just because it's
simple in design doesn't mean that it's
scary I mean hey this I don't like
that's just a good sound engineering the
way they got it like it feels like
something's breathing down my neck okay
let's not go into any building at all
ever how about that
it's right behind me is that a dead end
that's a dead end I'm not going that way
hahaha no way no how
what gem is that I have defeated yeah
for now wait a minute oh that was it or
nah okay all right well man that was
sure hang on let me see if I can explore
a bit more there was a bit more like
there was that other building at the
right there might be something else here
it's not a randomly generated level so
it's pretty much just the same layout
but there's got to be something else I
was pretty short if not very interesting
oh this just leads back to the other way
oh okay that might have been just it let
me let me let me let me let me let me
let me see something okay it's a very
simple very short game as that was
everything I think I'm almost positive
that's a dead end which means that if I
go off to the left of the gem will it be
a dead end
because yeah there's the gem again and
this is once dead and it is way where
does this go where does this go what
where does this go oh is this oh oh I'm
back here again why did I do that
why why this doesn't make any sense well
now at least I'm going back now hang on
let me let me just try and find
something else here there's most likely
something else besides that building
that building is most assuredly
yeah so let's not go that way I would uh
I would be kind of disappointed if he
was that sure yeah
yeah it looks about it okay come and get
me are you at were you at sukkah
where you at where you at where you at
where are you come get me
oh that was a lamppost karma gummy Wow
ah are you eyes to you are you stuck or
you're stuck angel
Oh Oh who's stuck whose dark like a
little trouble buddy
ah anyway Jackie get away you're
moderately creepy get back get back
honky kid all stuck on a lamppost
Oh okay you go right through the
neighborhoods so I see your tricks I see
right through your tricks ha ha where's
your brother
what are you doing ha my god he's pretty
he's he's just an obelisk type it's a
penis feasible no Hey look kind of I
don't know yeah
wait no hang on by the way ah okay I
guess I just closed out of the game then
okay so that's all there is so try it
for yourself links in the description
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotations for reviews that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
[Applause]
blood
ah